لم تفته اي مظاهره منذ بدات التعبئه ضد
مشروع الحكومه لتعديل نظام التقاعد يحرص
دائما على ان يكون في طليعه المحتجين يشرف
بنفسه على التحضيرات الاخيره قبل انطلاق
المظاهره بالنسبه له لا تراجع عن
المظاهرات ان تكن الطريقه التي سينتهي بها
النزاع الاجتماعي
تقييمنا واضح في عمر الرابعه وستين 50% من
العمال سيموتون هذا ما يعرض علينا لسنا مع
هذا الاصلاح لانه لصالح طبقه الاثرياء
ويهدف الى قتل الكادحين الذين يقدمون
الثروات لهذا البلد
نفس الموقف الرافض يصدح به هؤلاء فهذه
المظاهره في باريس ترجمه جديده لرفض مشروع
الحكومه الرهان فيها هذه المره ليس ارغام
الحكومه على عدم تجاهل غضب الشارع بل هو
دق ناقوس الخطر من قادم الايام اذا اقرت
الحكومه مشروعها وصمت اذانها عن مطالب
المحتجين
ما نلاحظه حاليا هو تمزق في البلد وحدوث
شرخ حقيقي بين النخب التي لا تدرك ظروف
العمل والطبقه الدنيا التي تعمل بجد في
ظروف صعبه وهي ترى ان المكاسب الاجتماعيه
تتاكل وبالتالي رسالتنا للسياسيين هي الا
تصوتوا على اصلاح فض وعنيف ضد العمال
في الوقت الذي يواصل فيه الشارع وتمسكه
برفض مشروع الحكومه تجري معركه حاسمه في
مجلس النواب سيتحدد فيها مصيره مشروع
تعديل نظام التقاعد المثير للجدل هنا يجري
البحث عن تفاهمات داخل لجنه برلمانيه
مشتركه يبدو ان التوافق مضمون بشان نص
يعرض للتصويت في البرلمان لكن من الصعب
جدا معرفه رهان القوه تحت قبه المجلس
فالحكومه لا تملك الاغلبيه المطلقه ونتيجه
التصويت تلفها ضبابيه كثيفه ما جعل
الحكومه تستجدي بعض الوان الطيف السياسي
الذي ليس من هواها
رئيسه الحكومه اكدت ذلك وانا اكرر الموقف
نفسه فالتصويت بنعم على النص لا يعني دعما
ولا صكا على بياض للحكومه وهو تصويت لا
يتبنى سياسه الحكومه وانما تصويت مسؤول
والى حين العثور على حل سحري لهذا النزاع
لا تزال اثار حركه الاحتجاج باديه في كل
مكان تقريبا عمال النظافه قرروا تمديد
اضرابهم فتراكمت النفايات وتناثرت في
شوارع وازقه باريس مدينه الرومانسيه
وعاصمه الجمال الجزيره باريس